the movie opens in the year 2003 and we
see a woman named Sonia and her daughter
Claire arriving at their mansion Claire
wants to see her dad Henry but her
mother denies her citing his busy
schedule turns out Henry works for MOS a
company that designs Escape rooms they
trap people in those rooms to organize
the survival games while the rich folks
bet on winners later on Sonia walks into
her husband's office and expresses her
wish to end their relationship this
reveals that they are not on good terms
Henry who is already frustrated by his
work asks her to take a breather and
they'll talk in an hour you can't escape
from this room says Henry as a result
she goes for a quick swim and then heads
to their sauna room while relaxing there
the door suddenly locks up and the
temperature starts to rise every few
seconds freaking her out moments later
some riddles appear on the steamed door
which makes her realize that her husband
is playing a death game with her
although filled with panic Sonia
frantically tries to find her way out of
the room she eventually solves the
riddle and finds a magnet hidden under
one of the lava rocks she uses it to
slide open the metal bars that are
locking the door Sonia manages to slide
two of them but her lungs give out while
proceeding with the last one causing her
to die inside the sauna the scene cuts
to the present day and we are introduced
to Zoe Davis and Ben Miller who are the
former survivors of an escape room
orchestrated by the MOs Corporation now
they plan a fly to New York in order to
expose this sh we organization on the
other hand we see Claire who has now
grown up and works for MOS however this
seems to be against her will because
she's locked inside a glass room and is
forced to make Escape rooms for her
father this guy is like the exhibit of
Escape rooms it appears that Henry is
planning to kill the former survivors
Clara argues against her father saying
that she understands Zoe because they
both know what it's like to lose their
mothers however dad remains Resolute in
his decision elsewhere as Ben and Zoe
prepare to board a flight the latter
experiences PTSD from when her mom died
in a plane crash a few years ago this
makes her so uncomfortable that she
refuses to get on the flight at the last
moment following this they rent a car
and opt to drive there instead after
hours of driving the two pull over at a
hotel to spend a night there at midnight
Ben has a nightmare in which he
experiences the room shaking and the
ceiling slowly starting to come down as
the situation gets intense he suddenly
snaps out of with cold sweats he also
has a weird boner for some reason the
duo then continues their journey and
eventually reaches the supposed Minos
facility within an alley although there
aren't any signs of the headquarters Zoe
urges Ben to look around the place
during this they are approached by a
local Thug who runs away after snatching
Zoe's necklace a Sentimental item from
her mother they chase the thug down the
streets and into a subway station
leading them to a train car however the
thug escapes leaving them stuck inside
with all H seemingly lost the two plan
to get off at the next station and
return to the building shortly after Ben
and Zoey sense something strange about
the train car especially the weird
noises as a result they check the
conductor's station and find nobody
inside soon enough their train car
detaches from the rest and is redirected
to a remote station with no button to
stop it alongside Zoe and Ben there are
four other passengers Rachel Briana
Nathan and Theo who also happen to be
former survivors of the escape room the
train stops at a dead end throwing them
all over the car as they gather
themselves the train becomes electrified
which makes them realize that they are
once again in minos's deadly game Theo
wants to get home for his wife's
birthday so he presses a button in the
train in hopes of summoning assistance
however he only gets a pre-recorded
message hi mystery recapped here it says
in today's movie you're all [__] real
realizing that they must play the game
to survive the group splits up to find
Clues Nathan discovers a hidden bag
containing a towel and a metal handle
while Briana finds a locked trap door
soon after they learn that they must
collect alphabetic tokens for the
conductor's slot machine to escape they
also notice a sign that says all false
advertising must be pulled in an attempt
to figure out its meaning they find
several advertisements with some
alphabet missing in it at this point Zoe
realizes that there are 26 handles
similar to the 26 letters in the
alphabet following this they pull out
the corresponding handles to each letter
that's missing which actually works they
then begin recovering several coins from
the handles as the electrification
intensifies Theo becomes its first
victim because he didn't know the
alphabet resulting in his tragic demise
with the rest of their Clues getting
singed Zoe looks at the letters they
collected and spells out the words
welcome back she then helps the group
get the last few few tokens and insert
it in the slot ultimately opening the
trap door fortunately they all quickly
jump down as the train car gets engulfed
by electric current after this they find
themselves in an elevator that leads
them further underground Rachel rushes
to open the door for the next room but
the others suggest that they act calmly
they then introduce themselves and also
share their past histories Nathan
discloses that his escape room group
comprised of all priests like him Banas
were all influencers how did they figure
anything out and Rachel's group
consisted of people who can't feel
physical pain what after a brief
conversation the group makes their way
to a room that turns out to be a bank
while wandering around bana accidentally
steps on a tile that triggers a laser
system trapping her in place fortunately
there's Rachel and Nathan who help her
off the tile they then notice a closing
Vault on the other side of the room
seemingly their way out however they
need to get the correct pattern through
the tiles to get there with only 10
minutes of time remaining the group be
begins searching for Clues they soon
find a key inside a lollipop which they
then try using in the safety deposit
boxes Briana tries licking the lollipop
but she doesn't have an ear-shaped
microphone or an audience so it's
uneffective as they fail miserably Zoe
spots a safety box which is labeled as
Sonia instead of numbers upon opening it
she discovers some blank bills with a
four-digit code hidden in it Nathan
enters this code into an ATM causing
four wall clocks to display different
times he then corresponds the clock
times with the tiles and proceeds to
test the route while also leaving a
trail of lollipops for the group to
follow at one point he gets lost and
steps on the wrong tile triggering the
laser and knocking him down to the
ground bana and Rachel hurriedly lift
him off the tile deactivating the lasers
with only one minute left Zoe finds a
chart with the remaining pattern of the
tiles and guides the group towards the
exit with Ben carrying Nathan in the
last few seconds Zoe makes makes a run
and barely manages to enter the Vault
once inside the group finds themselves
in a cave which soon starts to collapse
as a result they Rush towards the exit
and end up in a beach-like room wasting
no time they begin looking for the clues
eventually discovering a metal detector
using it they locate a reactive spot and
start digging they soon unearth an
anchor but before they can take it out
the beach is revealed to be covered with
quicksand that begins to suck Rachel in
how did Henry afford all this [__]
seeing this Nathan decides to save her
so he ties a rope around himself and
dives into the sand to lift her up the
group manages to pull Rachel out but the
Rope snaps before they can rescue Nathan
who is then swallowed up by the sand
despite the tragic loss there's no time
for mourning so they grab the anchor and
use it as a key to access a beach hut
inside they come across a locked
refrigerator which they believe to be an
exit for Indiana Jones maybe while
searching for a key to it Zoe turns on a
switch changing the daytime to night and
activating the lighthouse outside she
then heads to its top to find further
Clues while Ben locates the
refrigerator's key inside a mannequin he
quickly hands it over to the women who
then open the refrigerator's door
finding the way out meanwhile Zoe finds
an alternate route out by prying open
one of the room's decors she believes
that this will allow them to escape the
entire game as the beach starts sinking
the group gets into an argument as to
which route to take in the end Rachel
and Ben had for the the lighthouse while
Briana takes the main exit Rachel climbs
to the top but Ben can't make it as the
ladder closes causing him to fall into
the quicksand Zoe is left in shock but
Rachel convinces her to keep moving
before it gets too late they're just men
it doesn't matter if they die following
this the two make it to a manhole Zoe
who is overwhelmed by her friend's death
starts blaming herself Rachel tries to
console her saying that it's minos's
fault not hers she also reminds her that
they need to stop MOS if they want to be
free forever this convinces Zoe to keep
moving and the two navigate through the
manhole not long after they find a
ladder enabling them to emerge into the
city streets although Overjoyed at first
their happiness is cut short when they
encounter a panicking Briana looking for
The Clue this makes them realize that
they are still in the game since bana
has been there for a little while she
informs them that it rains acid every
time the timer gets to zero and that
they need a key to a rolling shutter
they somehow manag to locate the key but
it's not enough because there's another
set of locked doors the timer runs out
but quickly a sun shade pops out in the
nick of time to protect them just then
they hear a phone booth ringing but they
can't get inside due to another lock at
the same time they hear a news broadcast
playing on a TV in the store which gives
them a clue they need to collect the
acid water to melt down the lock the
trio acts accordingly and manages to
unlock the phone booth but they hear
nothing with not enough Clues to
progress Zoe steps off the booth in
search of the next puzzle piece but the
timer runs out on her thankfully Rachel
throws her an umbrella which everyone
knows is impervious to acid while the
two of them hide in the phone booth
amidst the acid rain Zoe notices an ad
mentioning three rings so she instructs
them to answer the phone on the third
ring they follow her advice and the taxi
door opens providing Zoe with Shelter
From the acid as the rain stops Briana
and also run to the cab but its door
closes to their bad luck the phone booth
also shuts leaving them without any
shelter they desperately try to find a
way in but to no avail as the timer runs
out Rachel accepts her fate and consoles
Briana too they hold each other as the
acid rain melts them down bana thinks
that if she were live right now she'd be
going viral on the other hand Zoe is
transported right outside cla's glass
room as Clare pleads for her help in
escaping Zoe know notices the blueprints
of the escape room making her realize
that she's the one who designed them
infuriated she yells at her accusing her
of being a murderer however CLA reasons
that she was forced to do it by her dad
in order to gain her trust she shows her
footage of Ben still alive also
revealing that she built a secret
extractor tank under the quicksand to
rescue his ass but unfortunately the
guards track him down and throw him into
a final room the sauna upon witnessing
this Zoe asks CLA to do something to
which the latter asserts that she has to
get her out of the room first for that
they must solve another puzzle CLA also
tells her that they only have two
chances left before the room's oxygen
gets cut out upon learning of all of
this Zoe helps her in decoding the
puzzle and eventually unlocks the door
but before they can run away Henry shows
up and holds them at gunpoint the
situation is tense and it appears that
the girls are going to be killed but
right then Claire's companion shoots
Henry on his his shoulder enabling her
to lock him inside the Glass Room riddle
me that [__] says CLA the girls then
head towards the control room to
override the sauna room and save Ben
from getting burned after doing so
Claire hands Zoe her father's car
revealing that her coordinates to the
minos's headquarters were correct she
also shares her decision to call the
police once Zoe reaches a safe distance
by the time Zoe arrives at the
headquarters the police and paramedics
are already there she goes searching for
Ben and finds him being taken into an
ambulance she tells him that the game is
finally over and everything is going to
be fine unless of course this is all
just another escape room meanwhile Clare
goes back to talk to her father through
their conversation we learn that Clare
was the one to build the sauna room and
kill her own mother solely to impress
her father however she expresses her
disappointment on how he took all the
credit for it in the end she enters the
wrong codes and cuts off the oxygen
supply from the Glass Room room
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching